Okay let's talk about our last data quality metric that
being uniformity. And we're going to look at auditing in
particular field for uniformity. So if you remember, uniformity is
about all the values in the field using the same
units of measurement. Let's look at an example. So here
we're going to work with cities data set again. And
what I want to explore here is just one field,
that being the latitude field. Now the latitude field is identified
in this data set using this particular field name.
So let's take a look at some of the auditing
tasks we might do here. Now the way that I've
organized this code is that we're going to loop through
each of the rows in this data file, and again
here we're using our tft module in Python. For each
row we're going to call this function audit_float_field. So this
particular piece of code is something that we can actually
use to parse any field that should have a floating
point value. In general this is how I like to
think about auditing fields in my data sets. I like
to think about the things in general that can go
wrong with a particular type of data field. And do
some auditing for that type and then if I need
to, I can write more specific auditing routines to check
the values. Okay, let's take a look at that audit_float_field function.
This is where all of the real work happens here.
So, what I'm going to do is I'm going to keep
track of the number of nulls that I find, the
number of empty fields, if any, and then the number of
field values that are actually arrays. And if you remember
arrays are encoding using curly braces and vertical bars to
separate the individual elements of arrays IN the info box
data set. I'm also going to check to make sure that
the value is actually a number. And then if it is, I'm going to run a check to
make sure that, it falls within the minimum and
maximum values, okay? So, this is a way of making
sure that it's using the units of measurement that
I expect. And if you remember earlier, we saw
an example where the area for a city is
actually represented using square millimeters as opposed to square kilometers.
So, what I'm doing in this particular piece of code, is
actually hard coding in some values for this particular field. Now what
I would do here, if I wasn't using this as an example
for this course, is I would actually treat each of these as
command-line parameters that I would input to this script. Here I'm
just going to hard code them in. So, if I wanted to
actually use this for a different field what I would do is
change the field name and change the min and max values to
test for a different float field. Okay. So, going back
to our audit_float_field function, again, we're checking for nulls, empties,
arrays, any fields that are not in fact a number,
once we've made it through all these tests. And then finally,
if I get down to here, I've got something that
I believe to be a number. What I'm going to do is
actually convert it to a floating point value, because of
course, all the values coming in are strings, and then I'm
going to check its range. Okay, now the range for latitude, the
way this data should be encoded is between negative 90 and positive
90 and technically speaking I should have made this less than or
equal to. Okay. So let's run this, and see what pops up.
Okay? So I found three non numbers. And you can see this looks
like an okay latitude value, just expressed in a different type of unit.
Total number of cities, that's what I expect. Quite a few nulls, actually.
Okay, not much we're going to do about that in this particular example. And
quite a few arrays. If I wanted to fully audit this, I would
need to take a look at these arrays and see what's going on
there. And then I would need to check each of the individual values
in those arrays. What I'm more concerned about, in this particular example, are
these. Now there are several different ways of representing
geographic coordinates. This is three examples where instead of
having the raw values for latitude and longitude, we've
instead got this type of coordinate, which is actually
degrees, minutes and seconds. So a different way of
encoding the same information for latitude. If I change
this code slightly we'll get a chance to see
what the bulk of the values actually look like.
Okay, and you can see that they are all values between negative 90
and positive 90 and there we can see a few negative values as well.
So, commenting those out, running this again. What's going on
with these values? Well, the story could be that these numbers
were coded by hand using a different coordinate system, and
that's actually why we're seeing this come out rather than this
type of number which is what we expect. So this
is the type of thing we might see when we're auditing
for uniformity. We've got a single field that holds a
particular type of data, in this case, latitude values for the
location of cities. But there's two different coordinate
systems being used here. The decimal degrees latitude and
latitude represented in degrees, minutes and seconds. Now,
in interest of full disclosure, I actually made the
data set dirty by introducing these three values.
But this is exactly the type of thing you
might expect to see in terms of the
same type of value being represented using different units.